Okay, so I have been tasked today to talk about follicular lymphoma and specifically transformation as a key event in a patient's journey.
So here are my disclosures.
So the take-home message clearly here is for you to appreciate the importance of understanding transformation from a translational point of view as a key event that we don't understand from a biology point of view.
And we don't have tools yet that have good biomarker potential.
So I'm starting here with a study by Sarkozy.
You see a tile that enforces that point that transformation events lead to lymphoma-related deaths.
So no transformation on the left side.
So lymphoma-related and unrelated causes of deaths are superimposable.
And in transformation, these curves shoot up.
So what's behind this from a biology point of view?
So in this study design that I will show you today,
we will be talking about the transformation of lymphoma.
And we will be talking about the transformation of lymphoma.
So we focused on an ecosystem approach in biopsies and paired biopsies from follicular lymphoma patients pre- and post-transformation.
This was a study that was carried out by my former postdoc, Dr. Sarkozy, who is back in Paris.
And single-cell methodology was key methodology here.
And then also spatial approaches that you can appreciate on the right-hand side of this slide.
Another very important point is that we have a lot of research done on lymphoma.
And another very important concept to introduce is the common precursor cell in follicular lymphoma,
which postulates that you can push disease back to a state that resides in the precursor state.
And traditionally, this has been determined by sequencing studies that look for overlap of mutational patterns in cells.
um is is more rare to to come by so here our our cohort design um was was really um built around
the availability of the follicular lymphoma and a post-transformation dlbcl morphology biopsy
you see here the um airs 11 pairs that we then studied with a single cell transcriptomics and
also single cell whole genome sequencing that gives us a single cell readout on the
copy number landscape in in these diseases you can see here it's a very rare rare resource as
transformation biopsies are rarely sampled or the biopsies are small and we allowed for quite
a bit of heterogeneity of treatments in between the blue and the red dots that you can appreciate
here and we also included a control group of non-transformers seeing here on the right where
with a minimum follow-up of five years
we wanted to study this for contrast so the main study objectives were to look into evolution
evolutionary trajectories we wanted to know about the malignant cell intrinsic features but also the
tumor microenvironment and then you will see in the end that we made attempts to create biomarker
assays to capture the tumor microenvironment biology so now here on on this slide you see
examples of
of you know the blue and and the red dots that you're seeing here representing the dlbcl and fl
time point biopsies and how they can be very very intermixed and very close
but then also how they can very far apart on the right hand side which we then
coin as phenotypic divergence and you see here that there is a negative correlation
with time meaning that the more time between the biopsies the more likely they are very different in
their phenotypic
um phenotypic features of the malignant cells so then this is also seen on the genotypic side so
just to say again so we just had single cell readouts on the transcriptomic side and also
the genetic or genomic side so we can superimpose this as shown here and the genotypic divergent
divergence parallels the phenotypic divergence as you can see in these time sweeps plots here
and then also the correlation on the on the right hand side based on copy number profiles
if you now bring everything together you see these classic phylogenetic trees that recapitulate what
has been seen by by other groups that you can go back in in in time so to speak to tranquil
mu mutations that sit at these nodes that you see um here as as the root or a common precursor cell
and then also the genotypic divergence of the malignant cell and then also the genotypic divergence
of the malignant cell and then also the genotypic divergence of the malignant cell and then also our
results very much confirm this model that we have mostly branching evolution and in some instances
also linear evolution with minor shifts only in the malignant population genotypes and phenotypes
so now switching over to the tumor microenvironment as this is of course also captured by single cell
transformation the central memory t cell compartment shrinks and the t cell exhaustion
compartment expands if you directly compare per patient the pre and post biopsies and as you can
see here at the bottom of the slide we see an increase of exhaustion markers on cytotoxic t
cells this can be read out with two marker combinations or three marker combinations so i just
want to guide your eye to the blue boxes here and compare them to the the red boxes even in the pre
transformation sample of tfl fl labeled here the blue box we have already a minor increase as
compared to the the non-tfl cases which indicates that there might be predictive value in enumerating
these cells in a tumor micro in the tumor microenvironment of pre-transformation samples
and with this idea we went ahead and validated this in an independent set of
folliculum fuma cases treated with rb or rcvp so two two treatment eras in in vancouver captured here
and you can see that with a threshold of roughly two percent of those cells you can you can predict
the time to transformation based on the combination of cd8 and black three multi-color immunos to
chemistry this can also be read out in a spatial context where you look at distances or just
enumerate them um enumerate them that directly so um to to summarize what what i've showed um so the
single cell analysis revealed the known evolutionary evolutionary trajectories um with evidence of
common precursor cells and now the open questions are where is this reservoir a key question that is
still unanswered and is this therapy dependence so i've showed you data on the tme that the tme shifts
toward an exhausted state and um now ongoing work with spatial transcriptomics and proteomics will
will dig into the diversity of the the mixes of spatial niches that are found in these biopsies
and finally there is a potential for biomarker translation and risk prediction by looking into
exhaustion phenotypes in the tumor environment and i stop here